et nous nous interrogeons principalement
sur l'organisation de l'état dans cette
pandémie le ministère de la santé et ses
agences a été l'objet de la commission
denquête de chaque nous avions
diligentée à partir de juillet 2020 un
qui sait a rendu ses conclusions en
décembre est actuellement notre collègue
bernard genier président d'une mission
de suivi de la crise qu vide à la fois
sûre qu'ils ont volé notamment sur le
volet organisation territoriale mais
aussi gestion gestion future de future
pandémie éventuelle
voilà donc je vous laisse la parole et
puis ensuite nos collègues pour vos
interventions vous faites un propos
liminaire pas pas trop trop long mais
met donc et alors merci beaucoup pour
votre invitation je suis évidemment très
peu habituée à ce genre de réunion
puisque je ne suis pas familier avec le
système français comme vous le savez
donc on disait que j'ai reçu une série
de questions on peut débattre je pense
que vous avez les uns les autres eu
accès et lui notre rapport de mission
puisque les questions sont évidemment
liées au rendu de ce rapport
je vous rappelle qu'on a bien un premier
rapport dit rapport d'étape que nous
avions rendu à emmanuel macron en
octobre et puis ensuite la mission a été
prolongée compte tenu de cette deuxième
vague et l'échéance de reddition du
rapport étaient liés finalement au fait
que emmanuel macron tenait à ce que ce
rapport fasse suite à la demande du
directeur général de l'om est ce que
chaque pays fassent la même entreprise
c'est-à-dire évalue face évalué autour
évalue finalement la gestion de crise
par le pays de la crise que vit et c'est
dans ce contexte là que nous avons rendu
ce rapport à la veille
de l'assemblée mondiale de la santé qui
a lieu chaque année la troisième semaine
du mois de mai et c'est ainsi que
finalement on a des échéances par
rapport à ce rapport qui peuvent
paraître parfois un peu étranger ou
décalés mais elle était simplement lié à
l'agenda de travail
la manière dont on a travaillé vous
l'avez certainement compris elle est
fortement biaisé par ma formation
scientifique
c'est à dire que nous avons fait une
approche quantitative comparative des
différents pays par rapport aux seuls
éléments qu'on peut utiliser aujourd'hui
c'est à dire la mortalité en excès dans
chaque pays
pourquoi on va peut-être pas rentrer
dans les détails mais je suis disposée
pour ça à toutes vos questions de
manière à pouvoir finalement gérer
malheureusement l'impact principal mais
qui n'est pas le seul quel hacker la
mortalité nous avons également et
c'était là là le côté absolument unique
de cette mission qu emmanuel macron nous
a donnée qui était de voir les aspects
sanitaires économiques sociaux et de
politiques publiques chose qu'aucun pays
n'a fait encore à ma connaissance
aujourd'hui puisque nous avons eu
contact avec 7 à 8 des pays qui ont fait
7 telle approche et la plupart ont fait
une approche exclusivement sanitaires et
la plupart vont rendre entre 2022 et
alors que nous étions finalement en
train d'analyser une crise qui
évidemment n'est toujours pas terminée
donc ça donne évidemment il ya un aspect
un peu particulier à ce type d' analyse
en dehors de cet aspect très quantitatif
nous avons eu une approche très
qualitative mais qu'on utilise beaucoup
dans notre domaine d'aproz scientifique
qualitative c'est à dire de faire des
entretiens et des auditions avec toute
une série de personnes dont les noms
vont rester totalement anonyme puisque
nous l'avons formulé ainsi dell d
alors vous imaginez bien que si on a vu
des préfets on a vu un certain nombre de
préfets mais on n'ira pas qu'elle tout à
fait imaginer qu'on a vu des ministres
imaginez qu'on a vu la société civile on
a vu des experts scientifiques
on a vu des tas de gens évidemment on ne
dira pas qui a été auditionné puis c'est
celle dans ces conditions là que nous
avons travaillé et ensuite nous avons
fait attention de toujours avoir
plusieurs experts celle approche
qualitative habituels ou en fait vous
faites ensuite des recoupements entre ce
qu'on vous a dit et voilà et ensuite on
s'est permis de faire ce rapport qui
fait alors c'est un peu décourageant
pour ceux qui ont envie de le lire en
entier
c'est ce qui fait plus de 200 pages et
qu'il comprend aussi deux cent cinquante
pages d'alex qui sont des annexes plutôt
scientifique pour lesquelles on a fait
une interprétation pour une lecture non
scientifique c'est à dire qu'on a on a
simplifié finalement l'information ce
qui nous a permis d'avoir une approche
relativement unique de la question tient
à dire également que nous avons été
totalement indépendant dans cette
approche est d'ailleurs c'était un désir
absolu des manuels macron lorsqu'il nous
a rendus en fin de l'ours qui nous a
donné la note de mission en juin le 25
juin 2020 et en disant vous devez être
indépendant et si vous ne l'êtes pas ou
s'ils sentaient qu'ils avaient des
influences dites le moi parce que je
tiens à ce que vous le soyez et ça a été
le cas on a eu accès à tous les
documents dont on a besoin on n'a jamais
été dérangés et voilà donc c'était une
mission que tu as un gros travail
je vous rappelle qu'on avait cinq
experts raoul briet qui a été premier
président la première cour des comptes
il y a il y avait laurence boone qui est
là cherchent économistes de l'oscd à
anne-marie moulin qui est une professeur
de médecine d'histoire de la médecine
d'histoire des épidémies et sociologue
elle fait beaucoup de sociologie
aujourd'hui est pire par nec et l'ancien
président de la société française
d'épidémie gs pital hier qui fait donc
le même métier que moi à genève et
c'était important d'avoir quelqu'un qui
était qu'ils avaient les pieds dans la
boue
en france alors que moi je les avais en
suisse donc c'est un peu différent
évidemment
voilà donc des très bonnes conditions de
travail et avec évidemment des
rapporteurs qui nous ont accompagnés des
rapporteurs de différents départements
et différents ministères que ce soit des
désirs est soudé des igas peu importe
mais ce sont des gens qui ont beaucoup
travaillé et puis chacun d'entre nous
avions un ou deux scientifiques jeunes
scientifiques de nos équipes pour
évidemment général et données qui ont
été générés qui sont jusqu'à aujourd'hui
relativement unique voilà en guise
d'introduction je réponds volontiers à
vos questions si nécessaire eh bien
merci de nous avoir donné ce contexte de
travail je pense que vous dites tv et
indépendant l'anonymat a dû aider à
l'indépendance des expressions pour mes
collègues le rapport on 200 pages pour
des sénateurs séverine tient bon
d'accord on est habitués à des rapports
n'ont donc mais il est sûr de le site
demeter façon à ce que vous en preniez
connaissance
et puis alors je vois déjà rené paul
savary et a10 présidé la commission
denquête et présidé nombreuses auditions
qui a déjà demandé la parole oui merci
de ces propos introductif le trick
succinct je vais parcourir le la
synthèse la synthèse du rapport les
comparaisons nous avons eu avec
véronique guérin et catherine navarre de
l'occasion dans le cas de la prospective
de faire un rapport sur le numérique sur
le numérique et la crise et je vois bien
qu'il ya certaines certains constats qui
qui qui se rejoignent les questions qui
me viennent de prime abord par rapport
par rapport à votre rapport c'est c'est
ce classement des pays plus ou moins
affectés que vous mettez en préambule et
que vous classer selon le nombre de
décès mais il est certain qu'il ya des
pays qui ont ils des stratégies à 0
virus 1
notamment en utilisant les moyens
numériques très strictes et vous dites
également dans votre rapport qui font
qu'ils ont un nombre de décès quand même
moins important que le nôtre
la france et 136e pays mondial en nombre
de décès avec une stratégique et celle
que l'on connaît où il ya eu un certain
nombre de retards d'ailleurs j'en
parlais également et c'est pas chronique
ça peut se comprendre
c'est une nouvelle crise on constate un
instant et donc notre stratégie qui
était celle de vivre avec le virus et
non pas la stratégie zéro ni russe avec
des mesures plus strictes mais non
généralisée les plus courtes ont montré
leur semble-t-il sur le papier en tout
cas leur efficacité
j'en sais pas plus j'aime dans ces pays
là mais il sent que ça mérite qu'on s'y
penche
le deuxième point c'est que vous fermez
de la faiblesse de l'anticipation
là aussi on a pu le constater et
notamment parce qu'en france nous
n'avions nous n'étions pas donner
forcément tous les moyens de préparer
cette crise notamment avec l'aide du
numérique
alors je voulais savoir ce que vous en
pensez si dans notre analyse vous avez
pu comparer est-ce qu'on voit bien que
un numérique peut-être un peu plus
intrusif mais permet de s'y met
davantage par le biais de croisement de
données
les personnes vulnérables et limite à la
durée et la globalité des mesures de
confinement qui ont été redoutables sur
le plan des conséquences psychologiques
sociales économiques qu'on connaît bien
et que l'on peut décrire dans l'ensemble
du pays
donc et vous fait une analyse aussi
précise qu'on puisse se comparer sachant
que le rapport que nous avons fait dans
le cas d'une prospective et un rapport
de constat d'utopie sur l'avenir pour
essayer de tirer les conséquences et
voir l'adaptation du numérique s'ils
nous avaient une nouvelle crise où on
peut avoir un certain nombre de
dispositions qui pourraient
éventuellement être intéressante
et avez-vous des préconisations de par
rapport à ce qu'il s'est fait ailleurs
d' justement de deux cellules de crise
pour anticiper les éventuels
prochaines crises qu'elles soient
sanitaires ou autre d'ailleurs
alors la première mais poser les
questions que souhaitait vous posé par
la chromie qui préside la mission suivi
bernard jomier ainsi qui n'est pas
présent qui ne peut pas être présent
mais qui a confié ces questions et puis
ensuite en on continuera avec d'autres
d'autres collègues de sénateur alors
maintenant je me et joli ces questions
parce que vous vous appelez a confié la
constitution la gestion des stocks
stratégiques un unique opérateur placé
sur la responsabilité du sgdsn
pensez vous qu'il faille revenir à un
opérateur dédié à la préparation à la
réponse aux urgences sanitaires comme
l'eprus où peut-on maintenir santé
publique france dans cette mission et
votre proposition de confier aux seuls
sg et dsn la responsabilité de
l'opérateur chargé de la gestion des
stocks stratégiques
est-elle justifiée par son
positionnement interministériel ou
s'explique-t-elle aussi ont en partie
par le fait que le ministère de la santé
et la dgs n'ont pas été en capacité
d'assurer une tutelle stratégique
efficace de santé publique france quand
ces missions de sécurité sanitaire ça
c'est sa première question est la
deuxième quel bilan faites vous des
comités des expertises scientifiques qui
se sont multipliées pendant la crise
quelles ont été les conséquences selon
vous la multiplication de ces comités
sur la lys la lisibilité et la
crédibilité de la parole scientifique
pourriez vous revenir sur les raisons
qui vous conduisent à préconiser le
rattachement du haut conseil de la santé
publique à la haute autorité de santé et
souhaitent vous faire du hcsp lenghan de
coordination de l'expertisé scientifique
en cas de crise sanitaire dans quelles
mesures faut-il revoir son organisation
et ses missions pour s'assurer qu'ils
s'appuient également sur l'expertisé
scientifique existant au sein d' agences
comme santé publique france l'enceinte
où la msl voilà les deux clubs her2
alors la première question d'abord et
dans nos propositions en effet il y à la
question de la gestion des stocks
stratégiques
et puis il ya aussi la question de
nommer un délégué à la prévention du
risque infectieux
parce que dans sa question une fait
aussi référence à d'autres façons
d'organiser le système qui ont été vus
dans le passé notamment à l'époque où
didier houssin que je connais bien et
est des gs est devenu délégué
interministériel mais ils étaient des gs
et au fond c'était également une
situation de crise
maintenant ce qui est évident c'est que
il manque et c'est pour ça qu'on fait la
proposition un délégué à la prévention
du risque infectieux
vous avez auprès de la dgs parce que
c'est un problème technique
vous avez aujourd'hui un délégué à
l'antibiorésistance qui est ce qui est
très bien mais l'antibiorésistance et
une partie seulement de la prévention du
risque infectieux
donc il conviendrait d'étoffer les
expertises au niveau de la dgs par
quelqu'un quelques unes qui supervise la
prévention du risque infectieux incluant
évidemment l'antibiorésistance ça c'est
pour la partie très technique et très
métier ensuite de ça vous avez la
gestion des stocks stratégiques cette
gestion des stocks stratégiques
elle a été déficiente on va pas revenir
sur la situation mais elle était déjà à
l'époque de l'eprus en 2011 puisque
quand leur et ex a été fait en 2013 de
h1n1 2011 puisque la crise était en 2011
à ce moment là on a déjà vu que l'eprus
avait des difficultés
finalement à mobiliser les stocks or
cette difficulté n'a pu que s'accroître
puisque l'eprus a progressivement fondu
et que finalement ça n'est pas l'
expertise de santé publique france que
de gérer les stocks
n'est ce pas santé publique france c'est
d'abord la santé publique de la veille
sanitaire
c'est la capacité de faire des campagnes
de prévention
ces deux là c'est de la médecine au sens
large c'est de la médecine et de la
prévention au sens large
alors de faire perdre de la gestion
les stocks à une entité dont l'
expertise serait de dire faut-il des
masses combien en font-ils par personne
et par jour et pour combien de temps ça
suffit
puis ensuite merci de préparer les
stocks d'acheter les masques elle les
stocker de faire des stocks tournant ça
c'est de la logistique
or cette logistique là c'est une c'est
un autre métier et il nous semblait que
effectivement le sgdsn en
interministériel était vraiment le lieu
où petit à on peut faire de la gestion
de stock mais pas faute de stocks
stratégiques dans le domaine de la santé
dans le domaine de la sécurité dans le
domaine dans toute une série de domaines
c'est très important donc un véritable
opérateur on peut ensuite de l'opérateur
peut déléguer la question n'est pas là
mais aussi de développer ce qu'on
appelle la culture de crise et la
culture de crise c'est quelque chose qui
manque dans tous les pays du monde qui
manque dans beaucoup beaucoup d'endroits
et de développer cette culture de
gestion de crise en centrale s'est fait
confiance en train de se dire en
interministériel que ça bénéficie
finalement à tous les ministères ou à
tous les départements appelez les comme
vous voulez chez nous ces départements
chez vous c'est des ministes d'accord et
donc ça veut dire que ça répondrait à
une double mission d'être en temps de
appelons-les en plan les en temps de
paix ou entendent calme préparez la
culture d'entreprise préparer là j'ai
vérifié la gestion des stocks vérifier
la culture de la de du delà de la
gestion de crise entraînée probablement
avoir la responsabilité en
interministériel d'entraîner dans chaque
ministère
des gens qui sont habilités à réagir à
la crise ça c'est ce qui se passe en
temps de paix ou en temps de calme et
puis quand la crise arrive
eh bien on active tout ça donc c'était
ça la vision c'était ça notre notre
vision de manière à pouvoir finalement
généraliser la l'aspect gestion de crise
qui est quand même là où vous l'avez
bien compris la gestion de crise c'est
un métier
et évidemment l'épidémiologiste
d'intervention parce que vous avez vu
qu'au cours de cette crise il ya des tas
d'épidémiologistes qui sont nés un peu
partout là ça c'était des générations
spontanées ya il ya un politicien en
suisse qui a dit je n'ai jamais vu ça
c'est une épidémie d'épidémiologistes
alors c'est vrai tout le monde se
prêtant des épidémiologistes
mais il y a l'épidémiologie les
priorités rhin et les petits midi
d'intervention et ce sont ces gens là
qui sont spécialisés dans la réaction de
crise ça n'est pas tout les
épidémiologistes et donc c'est un tout
petit tout petit petit sosie dans ce
domaine là simplement pour dire que la
la culture de comme une culture
d'entreprise la culture d'entreprise qui
consista à ce que tout le monde respecte
les consignes x y z face et exercices du
feu etc
c'est la même chose s'est il faut avoir
une culture d'entreprise de la gestion
de crise
et ça ça aurait un sens de développer au
plan interministériel de manière à ce
que ça puisse être utile à tous les
ministères donc voilà voilà le
raisonnement est dans cette culture de
gestion de crise
by à la gestion des stocks voilà et on a
vu la gestion des stocks cet acquis
chose de simple il ya du renouvellement
des stocks qui a des stocks tournon il
ya des décisions à prendre par rapport à
où se font si ses stocks et donc c'est
un métier un métier en soi et il est à
quelque part un peu injuste de le
confier à santé publique france mais
sinon c'est très clair ça correspond un
peu aussi inconstant qu'on avait fait
dans la commission denquête les autres
questions msm sur l'ice et le conseil s
p et les questions de rené paul savary
sur les données de santé 1 sur les
squats in alors il a beaucoup été
discuté en france 2 ne serait ce que la
nomination d'un conseiller scientifique
mais il faut bien savoir que lorsque
vous aviez une vision un peu panoramique
mondiale ou en tout cas aux européennes
ça a été partout pareil c'est à dire que
ça a pris des formes différentes en
suisse
le conseil scientifique c'est pas
appelés conseillers scientifiques qui
s'est appelée task force ils étaient
formés depuis 80 personnes avec des sous
groupes et ce cas en france
voilà on a confié à jean françois
delfraissy le fait de monter un conseil
senti que je dis bien monté parce qu'en
fait on est dans une situation de crise
en italie
ça a été le l'institut ils ont un
institut de santé publique très fort
très très bien constituer qui s'est
constitué un conseil scientifique et qui
a donné les conseils à gauche 1 3 qui a
été chercher les expertises
scientifiques
pourquoi je dis chercher des expertises
scientifiques ce parce que aucune crise
ne se ressemblaient les crises se
ressemblent d'un côté elles se
ressemblent pas il vous faut toujours
une expertise scientifique qui sera
différente
là il s'agissait d'une pandémie liée à
un virus
ok il fallait entre autres des
virologues il fallait des épidémies ch
de terrain il fallait il fallait il
fallait beaucoup de spécialistes mais
vous avez vu que même parmi les
spécialistes virologue
vous aviez certains endroits où vous
aviez des spécialistes du coronavirus et
ce professeur christian gross d'hommes
dont vous avez beaucoup entendu parler
qui est un ami que je connais très bien
non seulement c'est un virologue mais
c'est un corona c'est à dire que sa
fille qu'il a passé sa vie dans le corps
d'un virus ne s'était pas étonnant ce
soit lui qui finalement soit à l'origine
du premier test développer et extraire
une semaine après pasteur l'avait
développé pourquoi parce que tout le
monde se parle
donc vous avez je vous donne cet exemple
un tout petit peu idiot mais pour vous
dire que vous avez toujours besoin
d'experts scientifiques et vous devez
aller chercher les meilleurs c'est clair
il n'y a pas de raison ne pas utiliser
les meilleurs et donc la réflexion
elle était dans chaque pays de dire ok
quels sont les experts dont on pourrait
avoir besoin
et puis qu'est ce que cette crise va
toucher certains pays ont eu des grandes
commissions avec beaucoup de sourds ou
d'autres pays ont mis une commission
sanitaire une commission économique une
petit à petit en avant s'est bien rendu
compte qu évidemment
il fallait des économistes il fallait
des sociologues il fallait mais au
départ évidemment la crise était
essentiellement sanitaires donc en
france
la réaction est là était saine et elle
est logique et c'est pour ça que dans
nos propositions
on continue à dire qu'il faudrait de
toute manière toujours un
appelez-le comme vous voulez mais un
conseil haddock n'est pas forcément
scientifique mais dans lequel il ne peut
y avoir des scientifiques
il devrait y avoir la société civile il
devrait avoir les différentes agences
les différentes représentants des
agences les sociétés savantes de manière
à pouvoir aider au mieux à formuler des
recommandations pour qu'ensuite les
politiques publiques puissent être
appliquées ou au mieux et que notamment
les politiques qui sont ceux qui
prennent les décisions dans tous les
pays ce sont les politiques qui prennent
les décisions
puissent les prendre en connaissance de
cause avec un éclairage qui soit le
meilleur possible sur la crise alors en
france vous avez plusieurs agences donc
j'ai vu que vous aviez déjà repéré cette
difficulté avec finalement ces agences
qui ont été créés il ya de nombreuses
années un tout petit peu au dépend du
ministère de la santé puisque on a pris
des moyens dans le ministère de la santé
pour créer des agences et donc comme
toute agence une agence devient souvent
un peu indépendante et quand
l'indépendance et est là il ya ensuite
difficultés à mettre tous ces gens
ensemble et à les faire fonctionner
ensemble et c'est pour ça qu'il faut
trouver un meilleur moyen finalement de
faire fonctionner le système donc on a
fait quelques recommandations donc le
l'objectif y est toujours d'avoir d'être
sûr que vous pouvez aller chercher
l'expertisé dont vous avez besoin est
que cette expertise elle peut être varié
ça vous l'avez bien compris et donc
c'est dans ce sens là que vont les
recommandations l'expertisé elle doit
avoir d'abord les moyens c'est à dire
qu'il faut que les gens soient
intelligents mais il faut aussi qu'ils
puissent travailler il faut pas qu'ils
fassent ça en plus de leur travail tout
le temps il faut etc etc
il faut qu'ils aient si ce sont des
modélistes il faut qu'ils aient des
ordinateurs assez puissant je vous dis
ça ça vous fait sourire mais il ya des
tas
pays dans lesquels ils pouvaient pas
faire des modes analytique parce qu'il
n'avait pas les moyens de les faire et
puis il faut l'indépendance et ça c'est
extrêmement important et c'est pour
cette raison que nous avons pensé à 7,7
cette capacité que vous avez au niveau
du du hsa d'avoir de la has pardon
d'avoir cette indépendance potentiel
vous avez ce bureau hr csp désolé les
abréviations leclerc tient pas toujours
ce haut conseil de santé publique qui a
fait un travail absolument magnifique
qu'un c'est un travail qui est un peu un
travail de milice parce que ces gens là
sont habitués à vous rendre un certain
nombre de rapports par année ils disent
on 6,8 et là ils en ont rendu à l'appel
tout le temps et c'est un petit groupe
est dépendant alors ça c'est à la fois
une grande qualité mais aussi une
faiblesse donc ça il faut il faut le
corriger aussi et c'est sûr que de
préserver cette indépendance au sein de
l' achat s avec des structures qui
travaillent ensemble mais qui peuvent
conserver ce degré d'indépendance nous
paraissait très important voilà est-ce
que c'est la meilleure solution
il peut pas vous le dire je pense que
c'est une réflexion qu'il faut avoir au
part activement au fait que vous avez
des agences qui sont éminemment
compétentes et que comme toujours la
difficulté de travailler ensemble pour
des raisons parfois personnelles mais le
plus souvent administrative avec un
excellent d'administration avec a fait
que les experts ont de la peine à
travailler ensemble et voilà c'est pour
ça qu'on fait ces propositions là dans
ce rapport merci oui on peut rire on
peut aller sur le numérique tout de
suite si vous les laissez vous avez
répondu on n'est pas là il est bien
évident que le numérique est un outil
absolument clé il est clé à différents
niveaux
ça a été très particulier par exemple
chez vous pour plusieurs raisons en
effet
au plan de la réactivité du numérique
il ya eu des manques qui ont été
corrigés avec des avec des gens
formidables qu'on bosse et qu'on
développe et des trucs c'est vrai que
c'est mieux d'être mieux préparés puis
ensuite ya un autre élément c'est
l'accès aux données
j'ai beaucoup parlé avec avec arnaud
fontanet qui a pu mais avec beaucoup de
retard et malgré lui faire des analyses
sur les facteurs de risque en france etc
mais il me disait je n'ai pas accès aux
données et ça c'est un vrai problème
c'est que les données existent et vous
n'y avez pas accès alors tout le monde
s'en moque
quand il s'agit de se dire bah voilà
suivons l'évolution de deux points
d'après le problème de santé chronique
parce qu'on se dit pas si on allait
donner une fois par année ça suffit
peut-être mais pas quand on est en crise
on a besoin des données tous les mois et
peut-être même tous les jours
et donc oui il y à une facilitation à il
faut il faut mettre une vraie réflexion
par rapport à l'accès aux données par
rapport à la confidentialité des données
où on peut imaginer à mon avis on
devrait imaginer je sais que ça peut
faire débat on devrait pouvoir imaginer
que si une on décrète on est en
situation de crise il nous faut ouvrir
l'accès aux données
il faut vous trouviez les moyens
législatifs d'ouvrir ses capacités
d'analysé de données
parce que ça c'est vraiment c'est
vraiment terrible savez c'est terrible
pour le canton fait des investigations
épidémiologiques de terrain dont c'est
vraiment mon métier au jour le jour je
le fais dans l'hôpital donc c'est mon
métier
on investigue des petites épidémies
impasse heureusement avant qu'elle
devienne grande elle reste petit
ce sont des petits toasts dans un
hôpital vous en avez inclus vous les
cherchez plus vous les trouvez et vous
devez faire des enquêtes de terrain avec
des définitions de cas qui change au
jour le jour
et vous allez-vous
une infirmière un médecin un
aide-soignant un jour en lui posant
toute une série de questions en
retournant le lendemain pour lui poser
toutes une autre cette question alors là
on n'a pas de problème de
confidentialité
parce qu'on est en seul à seul et qu'on
fait du questionnaire simple
voilà pour dire qu'est ce que vous avez
fait hier pas quand j'étais aux états
unis on a investigué une 1 kloster
épidémique lié à une infirmière de bloc
opératoire qui avait déjà à la maison et
qui avait entraîné la première infection
humaine un germe s'appellera de caucus
peu importe mais pour dire que si on
n'avait pas été jusqu'au domicile de
l'infirmière pour comprendre qu'elle
vive avec une quarantaine de chats on
n'aurait jamais trouvé cette nouvelle
bactérie responsable d'un ours phénomène
en médecine humaine
donc pour vous donner des comparaisons à
bâle par exemple lorsque la santé
publique bâloise a réalisé qu'il fallait
aller faire des enquêtes pour que vides
ils ont engagé la police judiciaire pour
faire les enquêtes parce qu'évidemment
la police judiciaire quand elle vient
vous demander est ce que vous êtes allée
en discothèque hier soir si vous voulez
pas le dire oui non dans les sphères
politiques judiciaires elle a opposé
quatre cinq questions et enfin au fond
vous allez ensuite dire oui d'accord je
vous donne un exemple complètement
banale mais pour vous dire pour vous
dire que c'est difficile parfois les
petits des militaires alors si en plus
de ça vous avez un paquet données
auxquelles vous pouvez pas accéder ça
c'est dramatique c'est dramatique parce
que vous savez que vous pouvez porter
des réponses à des questions qui les
transports publics sont ils dangereux
voilà c'est une question à laquelle vous
pouvez répondre avec des données
épidémiologiques
si vous n'avez pas accès à ces données
publiquement voulait répondre vous
pouvez inventer des réponses vous pouvez
déduire les choses parce que vous avez
un certain degré de connaissance mais
alors vous avez les données dans votre
sac à main pouvait pas les utiliser
c'est quand même dramatique
donc oui il y a il ya des progrès à
faire par rapport à cet accès à la
données informatiques
exactement et ça vous aviez vous avez
des bases de données
remarquable remarquable
incapacité de les croiser et ça pour
nous cette dramatique
ça arrive de temps en temps quand on a
des des bases de données totalement
incompatibles on doit les retransférer
dans d'autres systèmes d' analyse et
c'est beaucoup beaucoup de travail mais
quand tous avec les données sont là et
vous pouvez pas les croiser là vraiment
c'est trop dommage donc ça faut vraiment
y travaille et je vous dirais que vous
êtes vous n'êtes plus loin pas le seul
pays dans lequel c'est comme ça soyons
clair faut pas non plus on peut pas yaya
il n'y a aucun endroit où on a eu des
données parfaite et même on pourra
revenir tout à l'heure sur l'asie si
vous voulez on rapport à votre question
précédente
il s'assure les données c'est quelque
chose enfin moi je partage le titre
personnel le beaucoup ici aussi le fond
je trouve qu'on est trop frileux par
rapport aux données est alors bien sûr
mais on perd une manne de renseignement
qui finalement peut avoir des
conséquences très importantes en
mauvaise gestion de la santé la santé
publique on va il ya eu le rapport donc
évoqué on n'est pas savoir et la
légation a prospective et nous nous
allons lancer au sein de la commission
des affaires sociales une mission
spécifique données ah ouais parce que ça
c'est vraiment vraiment majeur est ce
que vous dites de ce qui s'est fait en
suisse ça nous parle un peu compliqué
c'est hors de police du ticket en france
l ain côtés quand on a un virus qu'on
veut tracer si on veut isoler et si on
veut mais c'est autrement c'est un peu
je ne sais rien mais je dirai tout est
absolument faire compliqué donc ça vaut
vraiment la peine de travailler s'il
vaut mieux le faire en période de calme
puisque évidemment fait de crise où le
monde tout le monde vous accuse de dit
ouais vous êtes un voulait aller voir ce
que je fais liberté etc
non il faut le faire on perd de calme de
manière à ce qu en période de crise on
puisse y avoir accès sans débat bien
merci beaucoup
alors je vais passer la parole à
plusieurs collègues
et puis vous pourrez répondre à
globalement on va commencer par brigitte
nicolau ensuite formellement leur
hamburger martin lévriers et michel
meunier dont quatre collectes m'ont posé
question merci
merci madame la présidente et les
conclusions monsieur le professeur les
conclusions de votre rapport ne sont pas
tendres
vous indiquez que notre pays aurait fait
l'objet de bugs en matière de pilotage
mais vous soulignez que et nous en
sommes très conscients ici que la
mobilisation des agents hospitaliers a
été à ce point forte qu'elle a permis de
compenser toutes ces erreurs votre
mission donc propose préconise trois
axes de travail dont la préparation aux
prochaines crises quelle anticipation
préconisez vous concernant le variante
delta oui alors écoutez le variant dé
merci pour votre question oui on a
beaucoup parlé d' anticipation
encore une fois quand même remettons
l'église au milieu du village tous les
pays ont manqué d'anticipation voilà
donc c'est difficile on avait vous savez
tous les pays avaient des plans
polémique n'est ce pas suite à la grippe
est pratiquement aucun pays ne les ont
utilisés allez savoir pourquoi parce que
ceux qui les ont faits ne sont plus là
parce qu'on fait pas confiance à ceux
qui ont fait le travail avant et c'est
aussi des recommandations qu'on fait par
rapport à ça et par rapport au plan
pandémique notamment voilà maintenant
pour répondre aux variants delta vous
savez les variants les virus en une
évolution naturelle y font des variants
et si les virus ne faisait pas de
variants il ne survivrait pas donc c'est
darwinien le virus va faire des
variantes pour survivre alors on ne
parle pas de tous les variants qui font
que le virus meurt n'est ce pas parce
qu'il ya beaucoup de vario qui ne
comporte aucun avantage sélectif et le
virus va tout simplement mourir parce
qu'il sera plus capable de se
transmettre
donc quand il se transmet plus bas il
meurt il disparaît donc voilà le variant
delta eh bien il est né évidemment comme
les autres variant de la pression de
sélection que le virus ressent
simplement l'espace virus c'est un peu
comme vous vous partez quand il va
pleuvoir et qu'un pas appuyé sous le
bras
et vous commencez à ouvrir le parapluie
aux premières gouttes et le virus fait
la même chose
il sent quand il est au début de la
naissance de ce virus à leur tout début
on n'y étais pas donc on sait pas mais à
partir du moment du mois de janvier où
on a pu commencer à chercher les faire
des séquençages voilà bien vu que ce
virus qui est un coronavirus comme les
autres mais je me tasse et souvent ce
propos plus souvent que d'autres mais il
mute assez souvent
et puis ensuite il à augmenter sa
cadence de mutation pourquoi parceque il
sent la pression de sélection de
l'entourage
c'est à dire qu'à partir du moment où
ils sont ils pourraient être lorsqu'il
arrive chez un autre comme un être
humain
anéantie par la présence d'anticorps que
ce soit les anticorps parce que vous
avez été infectés ou parce qu'ils ont
été vaccinés à ce moment là il a envie
de changer
il a envie de changer de nature il a
envie de changer de moto et donc qui
imite donc il ya eu ce premier mutant
dont on a beaucoup parlé variant angles
m on l'appelle maintenant à ou alpha et
ce premier nuiton là on a bien vu qu'il
a pris de la place en angleterre et
petit à petit la proportion des variants
occupé par le var y en a a été de plus
en plus importante maintenant vous
entendez toujours que le variant delta
comme vous l'aviez entendus pour le
variant alpha est plus contagieux et
peut-être entraîne plus de défait de
mortalité que les autres variantes mais
c'est tout à fait normal c'est juste
normal
n'est ce pas pour qu'un virus prennent
le dessus sur les autres et occupent de
plus en plus de place il faut qu'ils
soient plus contagieux alors le variant
delta aujourd'hui il est plus contagieux
50 à 60% plus contagieux que le variant
alpha qui lui même était 40 à 50% plus
contagieux que les autres varions qui
courait à l'époque et dont certains
courent toujours d'ailleurs
donc petit à petit le variant il prend
la place des autres et c'est normal
aujourd'hui en france on estime environ
20% entre 10 et 20%
qui sont les variants delta petit à
petit le variant delta va prendre le
dessus
les bonnes nouvelles c'est que le vaccin
et l'immunité protège contre la variante
delta donc ce n'est pas un souci
peut-être que le vaccin astrazeneca
protège un peu moins bien que les
vaccins de pfizer ou modern a peut-être
mais il faut bien savoir que ou est-ce
que ces variants naissent alors on
l'appelle on l'appelait au début le
variant indien mais en fait les variants
les cons crains le plus
ils vont être dans les pays où on aura
le plus de vaccination parce que c'est
une course entre le variant et le vaccin
ça reste une cause c'est cela dont on a
peur on n'a pas peur du variantes qui va
se développer dans un pays où il n'y
avait pas de vaccin parce qu'on sait que
les vaccins vous recruter on a beaucoup
plus peur
deux variantes qui naissent dans des
endroits dans lesquels il ya des autos
de vaccins et c'est pour ça et ok oui
c'est pas paradoxal c'est parce que le
virus lui ils sont de plus en plus de
résistance dont qu'il a il a de plus en
plus de capacité à se dire il faut que
je change parce que si je change pas je
meurs
d'accord c'est un instinct de survie
chez le virus s'est pas de
l'intelligence c'est pas de
l'intelligent ne sont pas intelligents
mais ils sont ils sont logistiquement
bien fait pour s'adapter c'est de
l'adaptation
donc ce n'est pas une surprise ça va
continuer mais maintenant je rappelle
qu' il n'y a aucun varions qui résistent
hygiène des mains à la distance sociale
et au masque un espoir donc ça veut dire
que il faut que bah oui il faut le dire
je continue à le dire parce que bien sûr
que la vaccination nous permet
aujourd'hui d'ouvrir un peu qu'on
comprenne des activités c'est tant mieux
mais on va de toute manière continue et
à devoir être extrêmement attentes et
alors la clé du succès c'est qu'à partir
du moment où le nombre de cas est
suffisamment faible pour qu'on puisse
courir après tout les chaînes de
transmission et on revient à la pizza
musique terrain pour stopper les chaînes
de transmission parce qu on a détecté
les nouveaux cas et qu'on arrive à
contenir ses chaînes de transmission là
on continue à maîtriser la situation
parce que le vivre avec le virus c'est
juste une réalité dont on parle depuis
assez longtemps les experts l'ont dit
depuis le début
et ça reste vrai vous avez vu
l'australie qui en est à son 6e
confinement d'accord mais le virus ne va
jamais disparaître ce virus ne va jamais
disparaître
il a simplement apprendre et nous allons
apprendre à vivre avec lui vous rappelle
qu'on est tous on vit tous avec quatre
grandes familles de coronavirus 1 avec
lesquels on est infecté dans l'enfance
et 100 % d'entre nous pratiquement avant
des anticorps contre ces quatre familles
de corps à un virus à l'âge de 20 ans et
puis vous savez ce que c'est qu'un
coronavirus parce que chaque fois que
vous allez voir vos petits enfants deux
camps non moi j'en ai bientôt 4 bat très
souvent vous les embrasser de partout il
ils ont le nez qui coule est là vous
faites en automne un petit rhume et ça
c'est très très très souvent à
coronavirus donc ça veut dire ce sont
les virus qu'ils vivent avec nous qui
malheureusement nous font des petits
rhumes temps en temps des petits accepte
no money ya quelques petites épidémies
pour les experts donc ça veut dire qu'on
va devoir vivre avec ce virus que ça va
prendre des années jusqu'à ce qu'à 99 ou
100 % d'entre nous soyons immunisé
contre le comique 19 puis qu'ensuite on
en parlera on en parle plus on en parle
plus mais ça va prendre des années et
c'est vrai que la vaccination nous
aident à accélérer ces étapes avec les
ailes avec la vie avec le virus quoi
voilà ces explications très claires
vraiment merci c'est une pédagogie
formidable laurent burgoa oui merci à
madame madame monsieur le professeur moi
j'aimerais connaître votre avis par
rapport à la gestion de crise
quid de savoir s'il ne faudrait pas
aussi n'aurait pas fallu renforcer les
pouvoirs de nos préfet de département
parce que on voit que nos préfet de
département qui qu'ils connaissent bien
un lien avec les yeux locaux et vous
savez que nous les sénateurs
on est quand même les représentants des
élus locaux on est très attentif a
offert que les élus locaux soit associée
à toutes les décisions et
personnellement je regrette que les
préfets de département n'ont été que des
courroies de transmissions n'ont vu
aucune prérogative n'ont pas su
s'adapter alors qu'ils en avaient les
moyens et la possibilité si on leur
avait donné de s'adapter aux réalités de
terrain tonnes par an pour l'obligation
de porter ou non le mas moi je parle de
partenaires du gard en partie cévenol
c'est une aberration d'avoir imposé le
port du masque dans un endroit où il ya
un habitat chaque 10 kilomètres carrés
mais pourtant c'était la règle est que
si on avait donné plus de prérogatives à
nous préfets de départements allier avec
les élus locaux
je pense que cette gestion de crise
aurait été mieux appréciée par nos
concitoyens nos projets votre avis
là-dessus
écoutez c'est une très très bonne
remarque je pense que dans ce rapport
est de nous là là l'une des grandes
je n'ose pas dire qualité mais d'une est
un des grands apports de ce rapport ces
cas on a pu comparer comparer d'un pays
à l'autre et c'est essentiel parce que
en france
la difficulté du système vous avez un
système centralisé et il faut on appelle
ça chez vous territorialisée d'accord et
c'est vraiment la clé du succès c'est
d'arriver avec un système centralisé a
finalement implémenté sur le terrain la
plus juste façon de faire ce qui est un
peu contre nature parce que vous avez
vous avez toujours fonctionné comme un
pays centralisé
alors laissez-moi vous rassurer on a
comparé les pays centralisé au pays
décentralisé purement décentralisées
comme l'allemagne ou la suisse
on a des comptes des cantons qui sont
gérés par des démarches et vous
appelleriez ça des préfets et chacun
avait sa liberté de fonctionnement alors
pas au tout début de la crise au tout
début de la crise quand la première
vague est arrivée la confédération à
trion central toutes les décisions comme
finalement en france en allemagne et
partout mais ensuite il a fallu
appliquer alors on disait à chaque arrêt
pensable de canton allez-y faites votre
boulot et ça a marché à partir du moment
où les choses étaient simples mais on me
demande la deuxième vague
la suisse a très mal géré la deuxième
balle a frôlé à l'allemagne a très mal
géré la deuxième vague est
proportionnellement en france vous avez
eu moins de dégâts par habitant qu'en
suisse ou en allemagne alors que la
suisse et l'allemagne avaient été
relativement protégé de la première
balle et que la france l'italie et
l'espagne ont vraiment été les pays
portait en tout premier par la première
vague est au fond cette capacité de
faire travailler en région et d'adapter
en région oui c'est une clé du succès
bien entendu c'est une clé du succès
mais a contrario en suisse et en
allemagne alors que les appelons les les
préfets de région les länder en
allemagne un peu importe avait la
liberté de décider
vous aviez par exemple à genève pendant
la deuxième vague
tous les magasins fermés dans l'état de
genève et au canton de vaud à 60
kilomètres de distance tous les magasins
ouverts et qu'est ce qui s'est passé
tous les genevois sont allés faire leurs
courses sur le canton de vaud les gens
du compte notre frigo sont allés au
bistrot bistrot étaient fermés afribo
ils sont allés dans le canton de berne
au bistrot parce qu'il voulait aller au
bistrot ça a été vraiment complètement
chaotique
alors voyez quelle est la bonne formule
je ne le sais pas je pense que la france
a réussi à territorialisée à ça il
tenait beaucoup de monde au début je me
souviens les gens là ils me disent elles
se trouvaient normal qu'on fasse si
comme ça que vous exigez jaune verte et
jaune orange jaune rouge rappelez-vous
au début les gens supportait pas ça et
on aujourd'hui les gens le réclame
d'accord et donc ça veut dire que il
faut qu'on soit tous extrêmement humble
dans cette histoire personne n'avait
jamais vécu un phénomène tel que celui
là et que oui nous
on apprendre à fonctionner avec cela
j'ai discuté avec le dernièrement après
avoir rendu le rapport au premier
ministre avec avec son secrétaire
général et me raconte que c'est
pratiquement tous les jours qu'ils sont
en contact avec chaque région par
visioconférence pour justement pour
discuter ces éléments là et pour mettre
en place on appelle ça on épidémiologie
l'implémentation il sera il vous avez
des consignes que vous donnez qui
ensuite il ya la traduction des
consignes sur le terrain l exemple vous
donner il est parfaitement logique
aujourd'hui s'il fallait prendre des
décisions pour le gard certainement
qu'on dirait écoutez vous ne mettez des
masques dans telle ou telle situation
est effectivement au début alors que
pour nous il y avait beaucoup beaucoup
d'incertitudes on a eu tendance à donner
des directives extrêmement de type
consignes en suisse je peux vous dire
que les équivalents de préfère au mois
de novembre allait vers le ministre de
la santé suisse qui est celui qui a géré
la crise en dix ans reprenez le contrôle
en centrale on ne peut plus gérer
c'était devenu ingérable ingérable et
donc il n'y a pas de système idéal
il n'y a pas de système idéal il faut
être capable de s'adapter
après il faut pas que les lois vous
empêche d'adapter et faut il de nous
cette question de qualité du de la
capacité du rapport humain de dire
écoutez allez-y faites comme vous pensez
fait ce qui fait sens et faites le dans
l'abomination après comment adapter les
lois pour en arriver à ces situations là
je peux pas vous le dire sur un expert
mais je pense que c'est c'est ainsi
c'est ainsi mais vous avez raison il
faut être capable d'adapter sur le
terrain romieu tout en gardant une
cohérence au plan national les états
fédératif ont eu beaucoup de peine à le
faire je voulais dire c'est en débat
chez nous maintenant les certains disent
garder en centrale et d'autres ne le
veulent pas
pour toute une série de raisons on va
essayer d'avancer dans la question je
vais peut-être prendre trois sénateurs
et vous répondrez à l'issue des 30
questions
d'accord les bienvenus alors martin
lévriers ensuite michel moynier et
corinne imbert martin question est forte
pour ses engins et si on portait comme
si quelques questions je vais je vais
essayer de les faire très très court
comme d'habitude merci à vrai dire où
monsieur monsieur le professeur de notre
pédagogie que je trouve remarquable et
passionnante
donc je vais essayer d'aller très vite
vous n'avez pas des gestes barrières et
je vous en remercie parce que je crois
que c'est la base de tout mais est-ce
qu'il faut les prioriser finalement
est-ce qu'il y en a qui sont plus
importants que d'autres la distanciation
le masque ou le lavage des mains une
autre question rapide la troisième vague
on a vécu une troisième bague après
votre rappeur est ce que vous pensez que
votre rapport a été utile et est-ce
qu'on a mieux géré cette troisième cette
troisième partie de crise question
suivante qui pourraient être
indirectement un risque de quatrième
bague ou quatrième crise si le vaccin ne
se développe pas assez vite en france
comment peut-on gérer ce type de crise
et comment surtout pourrait-on retrouver
une pédagogie forte vis-à-vis des
français qui redevient un peu frileux
vis-à-vis de ce cher vaccin outre besoin
de se faire vacciner
une autre question sur la partie 1 cruzy
dont on parlait tout à l'heure le
numérique intrusif est liée à la
pédagogie des français ou à ce pays
assez rebelle qui râlent tout le temps
et vous le disiez dans votre rapport
plusieurs fois que la confiance envers
les gouvernants étaient mis souvent en
défaut et pour autant c'est le
corollaire peut-être les français ont
globalement très bien joué il joue
déconfinement donc comment trouver cet
équilibre
et puis dernière question à deux dans la
question très rapide sur les stocks
stratégiques
on ne pense jamais aux pompiers je me
pose la question pourquoi ne confierons
neupro pourrions nous pas confier la
gestion des strophes stratégique à ce
qu'ils savent faire c'est à dire les
pompiers qui auront cette logique
centralisés et décentralisés en même
temps et puis dernier point vous parliez
aussi pédagogie et moi quelque part
c'est comment allier aujourd'hui une
information fiable se passe à cette
démultiplication de deux choses aux
experts qui déverse à une forme de
savoir incroyable dans les chaînes de
télévision de
d'information publique de continue merci
beaucoup merci à michel meunier
si même la présidente merci c'est le
professeur de vos propos clairs et est
bien affirmée bon moi je n'ai pas lu
votre rapport mais j'ai envie de le
faire maintenant j'aimerais vous
entendre sur la population vulnérable on
a parlé beaucoup des personnes âgées en
ehpad avec la situation qu'on a connue
en france deux protocoles pas très clair
qu'on fût remis enfin bref mais je
voudrais vous entendre aussi sur la
population fragile migrants à la rue
dont on a en fait très peu parlé et avec
le comparatif que vous avez fait à la
fois quantitatifs et qualitatifs est-ce
que vous avez des éléments mano
communiquer là dessus
vous venez juste de parler des petits
enfants et des enfants là encore je vous
ai lu sur le la fermeture des écoles est
ce que ça faisait 2 catastrophiques pour
les enfants en premier mais aussi pour
les familles mais d'un autre côté vous
dites aussi que tant que les classes
seront ouvertes comme ça il y aura du
mal à ce que le virus ne se propage pas
il ne circule pas et sur la vaccination
vous dit pas d'obligation de vacciner
mais quand même rien ne se fera sans
vaccin sans vaccination
donc voilà ce ne sont pas des
contradictions j'en ai bien conscience
mais tout ça n'est pas très simple on va
dire d'accord corinne imbert et ensuite
vous pourrez répondre à cette première
série de questions corinne imbert on
allume le micro voilà oui messieurs les
auquel six professeurs de sujets que je
voudrais c'est fait c'est fait c'est
fait merci le présenter à ses
professeurs de sujets je voudrais
évoquer avec vous vous avez évoqué tout
à l'heure la création d'un conseil
adopte associant le scientifique des
sociétés civiles la société civile c'est
très large
est-ce que vous pensez que ou en tout
cas comment voyez vous
la prise en compte de la démocratie
sanitaire dans la gestion d'une crise et
est ce que vous pensez que d'associer la
société civile cela aurait permis de
mieux garantir en amont et une confiance
de la population et notamment de mieux
prévenir les hésitations de la
population en tout cas d'une partie de
la population vis-à-vis de la
vaccination
et puis le 2e 2e su gérer la mission
appelle à la réalisation d'un état des
lieux au plan national et régional des
capacités de soins critiques en
opposition j'allais dire aux capacités
de son temps normal est-ce que vous
pensez que que les moyens les
équipements les personnels formés en
soins critiques avaient suffisamment ou
autres avait au départ sous dimensionné
en sachant vous rappelez dans votre
rapport à ce titre que la la gravité de
l'épidémie a été hissé même race midi
mentionné sous-estimé ou à dire plutôt
sur la période
au tout début je dire de janvier à ces
flics et 2020 voilà il commet ces blocs
king ou m'entendais entendre ben oui
c'est bon moi je vous entends nom est
pas si vous avez entendu sur la la la
gravité des délits qui avait été
sous-estimée et les capacités
est ce qu'elle était sous dimensionné
mme pas au début et quel regard vous
portez sur la coopération entre acteurs
publics acteurs privés et notamment le
rôle des collectivités des et luxe leur
mobilisation à fournir dès mars ou le
sua drôle colis qu'au début de la crise
et leur mobilisation également à la mise
en place pour la mise en place des
centres de vaccination ban a choisi la
coupe alors gestes-barrières les deux
principaux sont l'hygiène des mains la
distance sociale distance sociale peut
parfaitement remplacé le masque on le
sait voilà en intérieur lorsqu'on est
plus proche et c'est le masque va
certainement aider
puis ensuite ça dépend évidemment des
personnes auxquelles
on est on est confronté si elles sont
très vulnérables non vaccinés enfin
voilà mais c'est clair hygiène des mains
est distance sociale
c'est quelque chose qu'on devrait
essayer de conserver au minimum
l'hygiène des mains pour pour tout un
temps et peut-être pour ce qui est de
l'hygiène des mains pour toujours mais
enfin ça c'est une autre question
troisième vague est ce qu'on a mieux
géré la troisième vague
oui la troisième vague a été très bien
gérée en france qui est très clair c'est
qu'est la gestion c'est un a cessé de
s'améliorer avec le temps et donc il
faut le dire c'est le cas dans beaucoup
de pays c'est pas dans le cadre de tous
les pays un c'est donc oui mais
nettement
on peut on peut répondre oui à votre
question par rapport à la gestion de la
troisième vingt quatrième vague alors
écouter des classes ce1 d'infection il y
en aura il va y en avoir et plus le
nombre comme j'ai dit tout à l'heure est
faible de nouveaux cas mieux on comprend
les kloster et dans l'idéal vous devriez
vouloir comprendre tous les clubs et les
interrompre tous et même 1 kloster avec
un variant extrêmement transmissibles
vous le contrôle et quand vous le
comprenez donc ça veut dire que tout
dépendra maintenant ce risque de
quatrième vague oui bien entendu qu'il
ya un risque de 4e de cinquième et de
sixième vague mais le la façon de lutter
contre ce risque c'est évidemment plus
les personnes sont vaccinées plus le
risque est faible puisque le virus quand
il arrive sur une personne vaccinée il
peut pas passer sur une autre personne
donc du tout rapidement le fameux air du
virus s'effondre n'est ce pas donc la
vaccination est clé mais elle n'est pas
en elle-même suffisante totalement
puisque vous allez toujours avoir des
gens non vaccinés ou malheureusement
vous allez toujours avoir des gens
vaccinés mais dont je vous rappelle que
les vaccins ne sont pas efficaces à 100
% mais ça on le connaît de tous les
vaccins dont on dispose
parce qu'une personne âgée vaccinés avec
le meilleur des vaccins lorsque elle
devient très vieille souvent son
immunité
même capable de l alors là on a les
vaccins excellent 90 95 % 90 95 %
d'efficacité
certains ne sont un petit peu moins
d'autres le sont beaucoup moins
certains vaccins chinois sont beaucoup
beaucoup moins efficace alors on les
utilise pas ici ben voilà donc ça veut
dire que oui plus on la personne
vaccinée mois ont la chance qui est des
classes d'importance et plus on
protégera notre système de santé
et vous l'avez bien compris protéger le
système de santé c'est pour la question
de protéger le système de santé c'est
sûr qu'on peut assumer les autres soins
et vous savez qu'on a tous dans tous les
pays du monde pris du retard dans les
soins et que maintenant il faut qu'on
récupère ce retard donc 4ème vague
il y aura évidemment aussi le tous les
éléments de l'automne
les éléments de la reprise puisque pour
revenir sur votre question oui bien
entendu que si le virus il va circuler
parmi les enfants
c'est cette vie dans et est à la limite
c'est tant mieux puisqu'il faut que
l'immunité de population monte à terme
un jour à 100%
n'est ce pas ou à tout cas à 99% donc
oui vous savez limité de population pour
la rougeole c'est 98 % à partir du
moment où vous êtes en dessous de 98%
là vous avez des risques de kloster de
rougeole et vous pouvez avoir des jeunes
jeunes adultes qui font les rougeole
chez lesquels ces cataclysmique
c'est vraiment une maladie très grave
d'accord donc voyez ça veut dire que oui
on va avoir des clusters oui dans les
écoles il va y avoir de la transmission
ça n'est pas grave en soi ça n'est pas
grave en soi
il faudra simplement éviter les trop
gros classeurs dont on perd le contrôle
et donc c'est comme ça qu'on va éviter
la 4e mal c'est en étant cohérent avec
les gestes barrières sans en faire trop
pour pas que les gens finissent par dire
je m'en fiche je fais plus rien c'est en
promouvant le test le test le test le
test c'est je veux pas dire c'est plus
important que jamais parce que ça a déjà
été très important mais cet été de se
faire tester et de d'avoir une
proportion de tests positifs faible
c'est la clé du succès parce que dit que
cette proportion de positivité augmente
ça veut dire que le virus qui est un
virus hyper endémique
il va être partout où il va il est
possible de toucher tout le monde et
pourquoi est ce que ça vaut la peine de
lutter autant et bien parce que cette
maladie
moi je ne la souhaite absolument
personne personne personne personne
alors bien sûr elle fait des gros dégâts
en terme de mortalité chez les personnes
âgées les personnes vulnérables
mais elle fait des sacrés dégâts chez
les personnes jeunes qu'on ignore encore
un peu parce qu'il ya du locaux vides
parce qu'il ya des gens qui perdent leur
travail qui perdent leur capacité de
faire du sport qui perdent leur kabylité
de se concentrer etc etc
donc ça veut dire que risque de
quatrième vague wii
comment lutter respect des gestes
respect d'aller faire tester respect
quand on est positif de s'isoler à la
maison et ne pas ignorer etc
et oui c'est passeport que vides c'est
parce que vides appelez les comme vous
voulez ces certificats commis on va
devoir les utiliser on va devoir faire
en sorte certaines activités ne soit
accessible que dans les situations où
soit la personnalité infectées soit elle
est vaccinée soit allé tester l négative
donc voilà je crois que c'est comme ça
qu'on évitera une quatrième vague et
mais c'est vrai que le virus il va il a
qu'une envie lui c'est de se reproduire
donc voilà c'est mais là on est quand
même mieux qu'on était l'automne ne va
pas être simple parce que la grippe sera
là l'année passée elle n'a pas circulé
ou très très peu
donc ça veut dire que l'immunité de
population est très très faible donc ça
veut dire qu'il va falloir se vacciner
contre la grippe
et ça c'est très important pour éviter
des infections mix covit grippe et des
surcharges hospitalières et des décès
liés à la grippe qui existe quand même
comme chaque année donc voilà pour ce
qu'elle la quatrième vague wii force
pédagogie vous avez raison il faut
vraiment y aller à faire de
l'information que les gens comprennent
pourquoi ils vont se faire tester qu'ils
respectent les consignes et puis ma foi
tant mieux on voit tout ce que les
choses s'ouvre mai
c'est pas encore la vie de tout ce qu'on
veut quand on veut comme on veut ou ça
clairement non ensuite vous posez la
question du numérique intensifs
oui je crois qu'il faut il faut arriver
à trouver cette balance dans le travail
allait faire parce que là vous allez
rendre service à la santé publique du
nhs à les rendre service aux français en
donnant accès à l'information pour
pouvoir finalement comprendre mieux ce
qui se passe
que ce soit en termes de santé publique
ou autres ou en termes de prévention de
maladies tout simplement août prévention
de maladies telles que l'obésité tels
que etc
donc oui je crois que le numérique
intensifs
c'est quelque chose qui est important
mais évidemment il faut pas qu'on se
heurte échos qu'on connaît les tas de
gens qui sont qui sont ils sont qui
s'oppose à tout ça au prix qu'on aidait
des révolutions je crois qu'on il est
normal et logique aujourd'hui que le
numérique prennent une place plus
importante dans nos dans notre vie enfin
tous les jeunes sont ont des comptes
facebook machin et rue qui sont d'accord
de dire des tas de choses et ils sont
sur l'état d'un algorithme mais ils sont
sales accordé dire si son homme ou femme
donc je pense qu'il faut qu'on corrige
tout ça et qu'on arrive à faire
comprendre aux gens l'importance les
stocks
vous parliez des stocks et du rôle des
pompiers pourquoi pas je crois que il y
a un rôle de centralisation niveau du
pays et d'un concept qui doit être
développée de manière à ce que en
centrale on sache qui se passe et où ça
se passe et qu'en périphérie on revient
sur cette proposition discussions le
rôle des des préfets des départements
ont périphérie ont plus à voir ce dont
on a besoin aussi vite que possible
évidemment avec une qualité qui soit
toujours là même où la meilleure
possible ensuite vous parlez de de toute
la problématique de l'info d'amy l'om
est sacré ce nouveau terme c'est cette
épidémie d'information c'est tout c'est
tous ces experts qui sont apparus le miz
la santé en suisse il les appelle les
turcs les turcs débarquer tu sais pas où
me disent et ils nous ont fait croire
qu'on aurait 35 mille morts en était de
il vint en suisse voilà et donc on a
tous vécu ça et vous avez raison
malheureusement ces chaînes
d'information continue alors là quand ce
que je compare la suisse à la france
en suisse on a la chance de ne pas avoir
ces chaînes d'information continue qui
certainement sont très informative ce
soyons très clairs
j'ai rien contre d'ailleurs quand on
m'aime bien vite j'y vais de temps en
temps mais c'est vrai qu'à ce moment là
il faut que ce soit les meilleurs
experts est le problème c'est qu'il ya
tellement de demandes que finalement
finissent par y aller
ceux qui sont disponibles c'est pas
forcément qui ont les meilleurs qu'ils
le sont et c'est vrai que ça a vraiment
fait souffrir le système j'ai même vous
dire au mois de septembre 2020 en france
probablement que ce phénomène a joué un
sale tour aux décisionnaires un sale
tour aux décisionnaires et là je crois
qu'il faut il faut qu'on arrive à
corriger ça parce que si on peut pas
dire tout et n'importe quoi
il faut dire les choses c'est vrai c'est
bien cette importance est démocratique
mais on n'a pas le droit de dire
n'importe quoi parce que là on met le
doute dans la population et ça on peut
le payer très cher pendant pendant très
longtemps malheureusement voilà ensuite
donc pour ce qui est de l'info d'emile
oms travaille actuellement à un concept
pourrait vérité nous c'est quelque chose
qu'on connaît très bien dans notre
domaine
quand on voit les choses à paraître sur
les réseaux sociaux ont réagi très vite
mais parfois le mal est déjà fait mais
en effet c'est très compliqué lutter
contre la mauvaise information ou contre
la mésinformation et vous avez vu que
les anti vaccins sont sortis très vite
ensuite ils sont calmes et puis de
nourrir sortent donc voilà c'est on sait
il faut travailler avec avec ça madame
vous parlez de la vulnérabilité des
ehpad donc on a fait toute une série de
recommandations pour les ehpad
vous savez les ehpad celle on les
appelle les im s en allemagne c'est un
autre nom c'est vrai que c'est un tout
petit peu les parents pauvres
malheureusement delà de la prise en
charge que
souvent ce sont des personnes âgées qui
vont finir leur vie dans ces endroits
mais malheureusement aujourd'hui on a
besoin de plus en plus d' expertise y
compris dans ces endroits là non
seulement d'un accompagnement mais d'un
soutien sanitaire et magne et médical
donc notre recommandation première par
rapport à la médicalisation c'est que
les centres de des expertises et des
personnes des gériatres experts puissent
aller travailler dans ces endroits pour
avoir une véritable compétence et puis
c'est aussi relié à la recommandation
qu'on a fait et dont je parlais tout au
début d'avoir évidemment un délégué à la
dgs pour la question de la prévention du
risque infectieux
parce que à partir d'un certain âge ces
gens sont à haut risque d'infection et
que donc il faut améliorer nos capacités
sur le terrain de faire la prévention du
risque infectieux dans les ai pas mais
c'est dans tous les pays du monde
pratiquement on les a fini maintenant
pour les consignes de prévention à des
hôpitaux en fait voilà on essaie d'être
plus discrets dans la façon de faire
mais ils ont c'est important et ça doit
être développée donc vous disiez aussi
d'aller auprès des fragiles et sécurité
oublié alors quand vous aurez là là le
temps de lire le rapport vous verrez
qu'on a fait tout une enquête
sociologique sociosanitaires en seine
saint denis
on a choisi la seine-saint-denis parce
qu'on peut pas faire ça partout en
france mais disons pour prendre un
endroit
disons prétériter des ou où les
problèmes sont finalement un une
pandémie où une épidémie c'est un projet
peur d'un projecteur sur une situation
et à ce moment là évidemment vous mettez
en lumière toute une série de phénomènes
ces injustices sociales
on prête une série de recommandations
par rapport à cela parce qu'on voit bien
qu'il ya évidemment malheureusement il
ya des des zones traitées alors c'est
vrai aussi pour la vaccination
il faut aller vacciner sur le terrain il
faut si possible aller avec une tente de
camping en bas d'un génial d'animaux
monter ce n'est à l'aller a porté le
vaccin finalement aux populations qui
ont de la peine à
à comprendre qu'ils hésitent à venir ou
qui hésitent à prendre les transports
publics pour une raison x ou comme tel
même pas les moyens de se déplacer
donc ça c'est extrêmement important vous
avez tout à fait raison je crois que le
gouvernement est extrêmement sensibilisé
à cette question et voilà maintenant il
faut que chacun convainc alors
obligations et vaccins bon ça c'est un
sujet difficile ça sujet difficile parce
que en effet un des soucis que nous
avons et nous sommes partiellement
coupable c'est que au niveau des
soignants il ya une grande différence
entre les médecins sont beaucoup plus
facilement vacciner que les infirmières
par exemple alors c'est une
généralisation on voit ça dans
pratiquement tous les pays du monde mais
en plus dans les mêmes pays
vous avez des ehpad ou dms connais mieux
les chiffes chez nous pour les ms vous
avez eu 98 % 98% pardon du personnel qui
est vaccinée dans un ems et dans celui
qui est à dix kilomètres de là 10%
donc ça veut dire que le rôle le rôle de
modèle ne doivent avoir les responsables
d pad qu'ils soient médecins infirmières
directeur administratif elle
fondamentale est fondamental parce que
de rendre la vaccination obligatoire
on peut la rendre obligatoire chez nous
en suisse on n'a pas le droit on est on
peut trouver des moyens vraiment de la
rendre non pas digues at war mais par
exemple les infirmières qui travaillent
en pédiatrie chez nous il ya tellement
de demandes pour aller en pédiatrie ont
dit si vous n'êtes pas vaccinés contre
la rougeole vous n'allez pas travailler
en pédiatrie
elles ont tellement envie d'aller
travailler en pédiatrie qu'elles seront
voilà hépatite b il ya des exemples mais
le coc vide c'est une maladie qui ne tue
pas assez a contrario des bollards n'est
ce pas aujourd'hui quand un membre de
mon équipe veut aller travailler en
afrique parce qu'on est beaucoup investi
dans des épidémies en afrique contre
ebola on a été beaucoup beaucoup en 2014
il ya personne de mon équipe que je ne
vais les que je vais laisser partir sans
les activer contre ebola
d'accord c'est logique c'est logique le
coc ville
les gens vont dire oui mais je peux
aussi la trappe et puis ça me fera rien
et puis alors ce qui est injuste et
c'est là où l'automne va être difficile
c'est qu'il faut absolument qu'on
protège nos vulnérables et notamment
dans les ehpad et ça veut dire que pour
moi ça c'est très personnel comme vision
pour ce qui est du début de l'automne
j'instaurerai une stratégie que
j'appellerais alors cette fois-ci 0
qu'ovide un petit peu comme ce que vous
avez beaucoup entendu parlé en disant
voilà vous travaillez vous avez la
chance d'avoir un travail
vous avez la chance d'avoir un métier
vous travaillez dans l'humain vous
travaillez auprès de personnes qui sont
dans des ehpad et bien soit vous êtes
vacciné
soit vous me montrez vous avez été
infectés bien sûr soit vous faites testé
deux fois par semaine voilà et je pense
que oui oui mais en france vous avez de
la chance parce que les tests complets
sont gratuits ouais mais en suisse les
tests n'étaient pas gratuit on a dû se
battre pendant neuf mois pour obtenir
une partie des tests gratuits donc en
france vous avez de la chance par
rapport à ça alors alors voilà il ya
tout un débat autour duquel il faudra
travailler parce que effectivement on
passe d'une éthique individuelle à une
éthique collective et ça dans notre
métier on le voit en permanence et c'est
fondamentalement important alors c'est
vrai que le débat des soignants et
autour des soignants il est extrêmement
important
puis après il ya le même débat dans la
population parce que n'est ce pas
aujourd'hui chez nous le ministre de la
santé est très claire il dit écoutez
nous allons nous rouvrons toute une
série d'activités nous allons reprendre
toute une série d'activités et ma foi
sur qui ne sont pas vaccinés soit ils ne
pourront pas entrer dans ces maxi et
dans ces trucs s'il présente pas la
drogue et soit ma foi il y aura des
desserts et puis il faudra quand même un
moment donné les assumer on ne peut pas
arrêter toute une société
parce que quelques personnes refusent
soit détesté soit d'être vacciné je
pense que là il va falloir continuer à
travailler dans cette direction là
parce que voyez par exemple la question
des écoles pour y revenir je vais dire
fermer les écoles c'est catastrophique
c'est juste catastrophique regardez les
pauvres petits italiens ici avait 18
mois qui vont pas à l'école
les allemands ils ont fait huit mois
sans école
et alors il ya évidemment l'éducation
des enfants
il ya les problèmes à la maison il ya la
violence à la maison il ya là il ya tout
ce que vous voyez comme problématique et
puis on aujourd'hui on sait mesurer le
pib qui a chuté on sait que ça on sait
mesurer mais on sait pas mesurer
l'impact de la fermeture des écoles dans
dix ans ça on ne sait pas et ça vraiment
c'est prioritaire est d'ailleurs au sein
du gouvernement ça a été souvent répété
y compris par emmanuel macron nous avons
nous nous battons pour garder oui garder
les et faire un peu davantage de tel
travail pour garder les écoles ouvertes
ça faisait sens au moment où on a des
mesures qui sont les mesures collectives
parce qu'on n'avait pas le choix d'avoir
des mesures collectives aujourd'hui
qu'on peut avoir de l'épidémie de
terrain d'intervention pour garder les
cabas on n'a plus besoin de ces mesures
collectives on a besoin d'une à certains
noms mais disons on a besoin surtout
d'être présent sur le terrain de pouvoir
préserver les ouvertures d'écoles et le
reste voilà ensuite
donc cette question de l'obligation est
compliqué on est tous d'accord dans tous
les pays du monde on est exposé enfin à
part certains pays on est d'accord dont
on parlera pas ici ou dans lesquelles la
démocratie n'existe pas ou presque pas
ensuite vous revenez sur la question du
conseil haddock
ce week-end on le développe dans notre
du conseil on l'appelle pas conseil
scientifique mais un conseil pour être
là de manière adéquate aux bons moments
dans lesquels on peut inclure il faut
inclure des éléments de la société
civile ans en france vous avez des
associations vous avez asos france un
saut qui avec des moyens qui ont été
donnés justement pour répondre à ces
questions et c'est ce qu'on recommande à
ce rapport on dire au moment où vous
constituer un conseil ad
pensez à y mettre ceux-ci ceci ou cela
alors c'est évidemment naturel d'y
mettre un virologue quand l'épidémie est
un virus et mais il faut penser à chaque
fois à introduire la société civile
c'est important ça aiderait ça aidera
certainement notamment aujourd'hui pour
ce qui est de tout le problème de
l'hésitation vaccinale opposé ensuite la
question des soins critiques
alors soyons clairs les lits de
réanimation les lits de soins intensifs
il y en aura jamais assez il faut pas se
leurrer on ne peut pas avoir quatre fois
le nombre de lits de réanimation qu'on a
aujourd'hui ça n'est pas possible parce
qu'on peut reprendre à d'avoir un lycée
une chose même s'il faut surtout avoir
le personnel capable de s'occuper des
malades
par contre il faut que la distribution
de ces lits elle soit le plus homogène
possible au sein des territoires
c'est à dire qu'il faut qu'ils aient une
vraie réflexion sur quels seront les
besoins
et puis il faut pas forcer ces secteurs
mais c'est le cas dans le monde entier à
ce qui fonctionne avec 98 % de taux
d'occupation des lits où 90 % de taux
d'occupation des lits parce que c'est
ces domaines là sont par essence le fait
de variations et on voit dans notre
hôpital
toujours cette variation ou en période
de grippe le taux d'occupation des lits
dette 120%
ce qui ne va pas et là il faut qu'on
arrive à trouver des bonnes mesures
parce qu'on parle des lits de soins
critiques il faut effectivement un
nombre adéquat certainement que l'ombre
et à la limite d'être adéquat en france
mais il faut être sûr que lorsqu'on doit
augmenter ses capacités
on en a les moyens et qu'on a les moyens
en personnel
ensuite on a beaucoup parlé des soins
critiques mais un peu moins délit non
critiques
vous avez vu en italie et en inde
on avait simplement pas d'oxygène
d'envoyer s'est pas seulement des lits
on a vu que l'on pouvait éviter
l'hospitalisation en réanimation en
oxygène ans les malades en dehors
la réanimation alors qu'ils n'étaient
pas trop malade pour aller à l'animation
il ya eu en france un magnifique exemple
d'adaptation de ce phénomène là et il
faut que c'est il faut que tout ça soit
réétudié pour avoir des volumes adéquat
mais maintenant ce qu'il faut bien
comprendre c'est que la vraie prévention
d'éviter la surcharge de l'animation
c'est en un mot c'est à dire de
travailler sur l'intervention de terrain
au moment où l'épidémie est là et
d'améliorer finalement les capacités
d'éviter que les gens finissent à
l'hôpital et ça évidemment
l'épidémiologie de terrain comme dans
tous les pays du monde a dû être adapté
en permanence en france elle a été l est
et c'est bien mais évidemment au départ
il y avait il y avait un déficit que
n'avait peut-être pas tous les systèmes
de santé publique dans le monde
voilà vous parlez donc on parle de ce
sous dimensionnement il c'est vrai que
dans chaque région
je pense que les élus locaux en
partenariat avec les personnes
responsables des hôpitaux doivent
discuter de ses capacités d'accueil et
ses capacités de transfert parce qu'on
l'a vu quand vous avez dû transférer des
patients du grand test dans le reste de
la france comme d'ailleurs dans les pays
étrangers et et bien c'est normal ça se
passe comme ça parce que tout d'un coup
le grand test a eu la malchance d'avoir
été infectés en premier par un phénomène
presque
il a très très très inattendu et donc
ces choses là vont se repasser donc il
faut qu'on soit mieux préparée
mais on a vu que quantité il s'est agi
de faire ces transferts vous avez réussi
sa magnifique mans on a vu aussi que la
solidarité entre pays pour la question
des transferts de malades a très bien
joué
a contrario d'autres exemples comme les
masques ou les tests voilà donc je pense
que oui il faut évaluer les capacités en
soins critiques il faut revoir les
capacités les centres d'urgence
vous avez tout de même un système de
santé pour ce qui est des urgences qui a
été pénalisée depuis une quinzaine une
vingtaine d'années on n'est pas en train
de dire que ça se passe depuis a eu un
an ou deux
non ça a démarré il ya beaucoup plus
longtemps et donc voilà il va falloir
reconstruire tout ça et c'est en cette
emphase c'est en train très bien merci
beaucoup alors je vais faire quand même
le tir de toutes les questions si vous
voulez bien puisqu'on a ensuite un
rapport examiné ce encore un peu de
temps rassurez vous mais dont canadien
sur le goût des questions rapides si
elles n'ont pas été posée sous forme de
directives mais oui madame la présidente
merci merci professeur de questions en
effet très rapide vous avez parlé de
conseils scientifiques et d'experts qui
se sont mis en place et je vais faire
remonter de remarques qui vient de une
profession qui a eu l'impression qu'il
fallait mettre le pied dans la porte
pour accéder et être là et pourtant ce
sont les vétérinaires qui sont avec des
experts des zoonoses et des experts
aussi la vaccination de masse oui je
parle à côté d'une collègue vétérinaire
et voilà donc ils ont fait remonter
cette impression de ne pas pouvoir
longtemps vous avez cités vous même le
cas d'une transmission par les chats et
long quand on aurait besoin de deux
vétérinaires dans ce genre de cercle et
deuxième chose on a eu la chance
d'entendre les autorités israéliennes et
sur la question de la quatrième vague il
parlait aussi de la durée de la
couverture vaccinale ont ainsi je
transforme pas si j'ai bien compris il
avait l'air de dire qu'ils surveillaient
avec attention le moment où il va
falloir re vacciner et voilà où il
disait on est prêts on surveille et en
fait la question c'est le top départ
pour vacciner donc est ce que vous êtes
dans la même démarche
jean-louis alors merci merci madame la
présidente merci professeur pour toutes
vos vos explications
moi je voudrais revenir sur une dans le
prolongement de ce que vous avez posé
comme question bernard jomier notamment
sûr donc que la proposition numéro 4 de
vos recommandations alors lui il avait
axé sur l'ex et prusse moi je voudrait
élargir un peu le propos parce que il y
as on a constaté en france notamment
effectivement des pénuries importantes
et des manquements importante en terme
de médicaments grosses difficultés aussi
au niveau des vaccins en pénurie des
médicaments c'est c'est pas c'est pas
aujourd'hui mais bon disons que ça
s'aggrave s'accentue il ya eu tout un
travail et beaucoup de rapports
d'ailleurs au niveau au niveau du sénat
et j'aimerais savoir donc puisque vous
prend vous proposait de confier la
gestion des stocks stratégiques
nationaux de produits santé un opérateur
unique si j'ai bien compris
j'aimerais savoir si votre proposition
englobe une mission de production des
médicaments et des produits de santé ça
nous intéresse beaucoup avec tf1 pour
sochaux nice puisque au niveau de nos
troupes nous avons nous sommes porteurs
de cette proposition qui est de plus en
plus soutenue en france d'ailleurs et en
europe
ma deuxième la deuxième question très
très rapide c'est que quand même quand
vous vous dites les transports les
transferts pardon des patients se sont
merveilleusement bien passé je pense
qu'il faut nuancer vos propos professeur
parce que ça a quand même eu des
conséquences psychologiques parfois
extrêmement douloureuse et même très
grave avec un isolement des patients et
que du coup ça nous interroge toutes et
tous sur le fait qu' il faut être au
niveau des lits et des fermetures de
lits et la jungle pas seulement les lits
commandé d'urgence enfin etc
je peux je pense que au niveau des
fermetures de lits en france il y en a
eu beaucoup trop et que du coup
d'ailleurs tous les professionnels le
disent on est on est coincé parce que
effectivement il n'y a pas la
possibilité il n'y a pas la capacité
hospitalière d'accueil des patients ces
dernières chassaing
ça semble très rapide donc monsieur le
professeur merci donc que vous avez dit
qu'il fallait être humble pour dans la
critique de la gestion je crois que
j'aurais parce que il est vrai que 1 en
janvier même le ministre de la santé
indiquait que s demandé à en janvier
2020 si ça allait venir en europe donc
après bien sûr lorsque on a des
médicaments comme les investisse qui
sont multipliées par mille en
consommation va se compliquer pour tous
les
gouvernement dans tous les pays donc ils
les jets les questions en fait que je
voulais poser vous avez répondu
partiellement
je pense qu'on a beaucoup eu beaucoup de
difficultés de retard pour tester testé
massivement et surtout isoler les
contacts et comment on peut mieux se
préparer pour le faire et le faire
accepter par la population et concernant
les vaccins pour les soignants vous y
avait deux tons merci centrale de seine
merci madame la présidente professeur
vous avez indiqué dans l'une de vos
réponses que la population à 20 ans
étaient pratiquement totalement immunisé
contre quatre familles de coronavirus
est-ce que vous avez des mesures et des
retours sur l'immunité des enfants qui
ont été exposés au virus et que
pensez-vous de la vaccination des
enfants opérés chez président monsieur
le professeur m'a promis ma première
question rejoint celle de ma collègue
nadia sur le goût on entendit parler de
3e vaccination dans l'aude à la
troisième dose donc avoir votre votre
retour et puis dans votre rapport vous
parlez des retards de diagnostic
notamment concernant le cancer est ce
que pourrait provoquer comme
surmortalité ces reports alors il ya un
cancer certainement d'autres maladies là
vous appuyez sur un article de la revue
27 notamment au royaume uni en mai et en
août 2020 en disant que cette
surmortalité pourrait s'étaler sur les
cinq ans à venir quels sont les
préconisations puisqu'on parle de
cinquième sixième vague
merci jocelyne guide s ensuivront senti
et niamey et on passera aux réponses
nationales à plein des professeurs
l'armée a une certaine expérience de
gestion de crise il faut des exercices
régulièrement sur d éventuelles attaques
chimiques voire au virus
je voudrais savoir s'ils ont pu apporter
leurs expériences et les avez-vous
auditionnés via questions sur l'armé de
la présidente groupe d'étude du monde
combattant
merci
dis donc professeur pardon lorsqu'on
vous demande si vous pensez que vos
recommandations seront suivies d'effet
vous répondez bien sûr que vous espérez
avoir été utile et nous l'espérons aussi
pour vous seulement vous émettez une
petite déception dans cette mission
c'est de ne pas avoir eu le temps
d'aborder l'aspect de la recherche
scientifique et pharmaceutique vous dit
même qu'on aurait pu espérer qu'une
nation comme la france soit à l'origine
de traitement et de vaccins est ce que
vous pouvez me développer s'il brûlé et
enfin pour finir un échec mais merci
professeur dans ma collègue nadia a posé
la question sur le nucléaire dont
j'aimerais la réponse avec attention
on constate l'année dernière et cette
année que finalement en était cette
vague semble être vraiment son niveau le
plus bas
alors au bout de ces deux années et ce
qu'on a déjà identifié les corps c'est
ce que c'est climatique est ce que c'est
les confinements antérieures qui ont
permis d'avoir cette accalmie est ce
qu'on peut déjà tirer des conclusions
pour les années futures
puisque vous nous avez annoncé ce que je
partage d'ailleurs qu'on en a pour
quelques annexes virus vous parliez
délit aussi ce qu à ce jour on a
suffisamment de recul sur les
traitements mis en place plus
précocément pour limiter justement c'est
ce besoin de l'ide de grandes
réanimation finalement et la troisième
chose on parlait des documents tout à
l'heure je sais qu'on avait auditionné
un monsieur dont j'ai oublié le nom mais
les chiffres qui nous avait indiqué
m'avait assez interpellé il parlait de
cinq milliards de documents qui avaient
été publiées à ce jour et que l'huile
aurait besoin de 6 en lisant 24 heures
sur 24 pour absorber toute cette
publication alors finalement comment est
ce que vous arrivez et comment est ce
que les médias ou arrive à faire le tri
dans toutes ces informations qui sont
publiés et comment est ce qu'elles
peuvent être finalement contrôlé maxi
pas la dernière
alors conseil scientifique vétérinaire
oui il a été rajouté donc ces faits
c'était peut-être un peu tardif mais
séchez et puis effectivement dans la
discussion
on aimerait avoir cette discussion sur
le one r c'est à dire d'avoir une
déléguée pour la prévention du risque
infectieux qui soit aussi rattaché
fonctionnellement avec
l'interministériel pour justement faire
du one ce qui est vraiment le demain
quoi on est tous d'accord avec ça après
c'est compliqué je vous rappelle que
jusqu'à il ya dix ans quand on a on a
fait des recommandations à l'om est-ce
pour aller travailler avec
l'organisation mondiale de la santé
animale
c'était je crois en 2013 ou en 2012 je
me suis enfui très bien il ne s'était
jamais parlé en fait et c'est très
curieux mais il ya eu une grande au
niveau mondial donc voilà donc il ya
déjà des progrès qui ont été faits il
faut que ça continue il faut qu'on
prenne l'habitude de travailler ensemble
que surtout quand on parle de zoonoses
vous avez tout à fait raison
[Musique]